[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAJESH MISHRA: Hello, everyone.
My name is Rajesh Mishra.
I'm an engineering lead on the
GCE team doing control plane
work.
I'm joined here by
my colleague, Vikas.
VIKAS YADAV: Hi, everyone.
I am Vikas Yadav.
I am an engineer on GCP, and
I support the storage solution
for GCE.
RAJESH MISHRA: So
what we plan to cover
is how we design our control
plane to be highly available.
So let's get started.
So before we get started,
let's talk about control plane
at a very high level.
So we have an extremely
simplified version
from a customer standpoint.
So what you see
over here, what it
takes to orchestrate an API that
you submit against our control
plane.
So I've picked a canonical
example of submitting
an instance creation request.
So that API, we
orchestrate that API.
That API has many, many
steps to be performed.
So I just listed a
few of the steps.
We need to check the permission.
We need to check the
[? org ?] policy,
[? coda, ?] so on and so forth.
Any one of these
steps could fail.
And you can imagine
control plane
with many projects,
many resources
that we manage, many APIs
that we need to process.
We need to process and
remember where we are exactly
so we can recover our failures.
And since this talk is
about the availability,
let's define what
is availability.
So our SRE reliability
workbook defines availability
as an uptime of a
software service.
And the way we calculate
our availability
is by accumulating all the
unavailable periods of downtime
over some window of time.
So as an example,
four-nines implies
your service was unavailable
over a 30-day for 4.3 minutes,
and so on and so forth.
There are a couple of
dimensions to availability
for a GCE system.
The VN uptime availability,
this is nothing
but your VMs are programmed,
the network is being configured,
your PD is configured,
and all the other stuff
has been programmed
by the control plane,
and your resources are
now serving live traffic.
That we call VM
uptime availability.
Just to draw some
distinction, we
have control plane
availability, which is basically
an on-demand control plane
programming that happens
via one of our REST APIs.
And at a very high level,
the control plane programming
centers are on three
key resources--
the VM-- the Virtual
Machines; the PDs;
and any kind of network
access you configure.
And there are many more
resources, of course,
and I haven't listed them.
So it's important to remember
the distinction about these two
availability things.
The first one is live
traffic serving paths.
The second is control paths.
We're so proud of
the availability
work they have done that we have
a published SLA for VM uptime.
So for VMs that leverage
our multiple region,
so, for example, VMs placed in
two or more zones in a region
or it could be split
across region--
one can expect an aggregate
uptime availability four-nines.
And this would be with no
loss of external connectivity
or access to persistent disk.
Most importantly, this will be
without any kind of downtime,
and will be transferring
even if we carry out
any kind of host maintenance.
So if you have to carry out
any kind of security patches,
we'll do that transparently
by live migrating your VMs.
And in most cases,
you won't notice that.
VIKAS YADAV: So in
the previous slide,
the security patches
we are talking
about it is the
underlying system on top
of which the VMs run.
And we do line migration
when we are patching
the host on which the VM run.
RAJESH MISHRA: So while I
talked about the VM uptime
availability, we
don't have an SLA
that we published for
our control plane,
but the internal
work they have done,
we're very proud of what we have
achieved, the designs that we
have that we'll talk the rest of
the presentation on our control
plane availability.
So as you guys know--
sorry, before we
get started, I need
to introduce some
key concepts that
are important in the VM that are
important in our control plane.
So as you guys know, we
serve 17 regions globally.
Each region can have multiple
zones, at least three or more.
And they are spread globally.
Regions are connected to
extremely fast network
and highly available network.
So any given region will
have at least multiple
redundant network paths, which
is, as Brad Calder pointed out
earlier this morning, it's a
pretty key point off Google
Cloud Platform.
The rest of the
presentation we're
going to talk through
some of the design
points that have
worked really well
as we work to offer a highly
available control plane.
And this is the system that
offers all the API we serve.
So I need to introduce some
key building block foundations
before we get started.
So this is a GCE
resource data model.
Resources like VMs and
disks are zonal resources.
Sub-networks, static
IPs, regional disks--
these are shared
resources, but they're
shared across within a region.
Global resources-- the
most important ones
are images, Snapshots,
and InstanceTemplate.
They are shared across
globally by all the regions.
So you can imagine this, in
a very object-oriented sense,
you have a hierarchical
access pattern.
And we'll talk through this.
And we'll refer
to this data model
as we explain the
kind of choices
we made to build a highly
available control plane.
So Vikas, you should
just jump in as--
VIKAS YADAV: Yeah, I want to
spend some more time here.
So we have a
concept of resources
which are available globally.
So what that means is if you
have an instance template which
you want to use to launch
VMs in multiple regions,
you are to define
it only once, and it
will be available in your entire
project across all the regions.
You don't have to create
a separate template
for a different region.
So in some sense, this provide
simplicity of management
and a single pane of control.
And similarly, there
are some resources
which are region
specific, which are used
by all the zones in the region.
And they follow
a natural pattern
like IP addresses, which are
local to the region, which
can be used within the
zones in the region.
And this natural hierarchy
of sharding of the data model
helps us achieve
high availability,
as we will talk about in the
rest of the presentation.
RAJESH MISHRA: So
some of this will
start to make a lot of
sense as we dive deeper
into the rest of the discussion.
So we could have chosen a design
to have control plane sorted
out of a single
scope, have everything
be global with a
[? sorted out ?]
global state database.
But as we know, that's a
single point of failure.
This could work
as an improvement
over the previous design.
So what you see is each
individual scopes, all
the scope data model
that I talked about,
resources that are in
the individual scope,
they're sorted out of the
individual control planes.
However, in this case,
we're sharing a database.
That, again, is a
single point of failure.
One key point here
that I talk about
from a topology standpoint,
we have a frontend--
we have our Google
frontend, which
is nothing but a service
router, and there
is a second level
of router we have,
which I've called it
here as API dispatcher.
And all it does is
it's a scope parser.
So in our URL path, all
our resources are scoped.
So you could reference,
let's say, a disk.
And a disk, as we know,
is a [? zonoscope. ?]
So based on the
specific zonoscope
that you are interested
in, the right control plane
will be involved here.
It's important to also
call out that there is only
one singleton global scope.
And we serve 17 regions, so
there are 17 regional scopes.
And likewise, there are--
and I just made a very
gross generalization
that there are three
zones per region,
so about 51 independent control
planes serving resources
within the scope.
So this is the final design.
This is what we
have in production.
This is what we use.
We have independent
control plane
with their own
independent databases.
VIKAS YADAV: So the theme here
is if you want availability,
you need to minimize
shared point of failures.
So the slide number one, there's
a single stack, which is not
going to work for availability.
Second slide, things
are independent,
but there is a shared
database, which,
again, reduces availability.
Having independent
controls stacks increases
the aggregate availability,
because there is no shared
fate between those stacks.
And that's what we
have zeroed in on,
that we are not going
to have shared fate
across the different stacks, and
have multiple different stacks
for different scopes.
RAJESH MISHRA: Another key
point that we felt was sharing.
As we design our system,
what about config?
And what about updating all the
scope control plane binaries?
The model we have chosen is we
do multi-day phased rollout.
And this is largely
to limit blast radius.
So there are some
config that needs
to be rolled out globally
across all the control planes
that we serve, and we do this
in a very staged fashion.
We have circuit
breakers along the way,
and we do a lot of monitoring
as we tier the rollout.
So we watch rollout.
We do zone by zone roll out.
And based on the success,
we will take it forward.
And over some short
period of time,
the rollouts are completed.
And then you get a new
version of control plane
if there are any config changes.
We do a lot of
[? offerant ?] validation.
We presubmit testing
and staging testing.
So that's our design
point number two.
Let's spend some
time on something
that we have internally
started to call Rule of Nine.
And what this, simply stated--
assume you're trying to provide
a service called Service A,
and it's serving a critical API.
This could be your GCE system
serving CreateInstance API.
And Service A is built on a lot
of internal services we have--
identity as an example,
an access check.
A lot of these
underlying dependencies
need to offer at
least an availability
that is higher than
what I'm trying
to provide to our customers.
And you can imagine, end
layer of dependencies
and will go higher
at every layer below.
And that's the Rule of Nine.
So we followed this very
diligently by inspecting
all the [? differences ?]
across the board.
So that's design
point number three.
The subsequent discussion--
since this talk
is about distributed systems
and serving control plane
availability, let's
spend a minute
to talk about CAP Theorem.
So CAP Theorem stated there
are three key factors or three
key design consideration points
in any distributed system
design.
So distributed systems
are partitioned by nature.
So that's how much
partition tolerance
you need to build
for your use cases.
Availability and consistency
are the other two parameters
that you can play with.
CAP Theorem states that you
can pick only two of these,
and you're probably trading
off on the third one.
And that's what in the
intersection of all three,
that's almost an
impossible thing to build.
So you could either end
up with a system that
is either consistent
and available
at the same time--
that's typically
all the old-school single
server model, or more than often
in a distributed
system, availability
is extremely important, which
has been the kind of choices
that we made for a
lot of our design.
And we picked AP-based model.
In some cases, you might have
consistency and partition
tolerance if it's a
shared global object.
And we'll talk about
that subsequently.
So here what I have,
an example, where
we do some kind of lazy
state reconciliation.
So imagine there is a
critical API being served out
of your service, and there is
a dependency layer below it.
You could pick a choice
where you fail-close,
and you need to reconcile
the state synchronously.
In a partitioned system
this can be tricky.
And for some cases,
we felt instead
of improving availability
it was acceptable to just do
a fail-open.
VIKAS YADAV: Yeah, so one
example I'll bring up here
is, in your application
as well, if you
have high availability
for your API,
but you have a dependency which
is not a critical dependency
and you can live with
fail-open semantics,
then you don't have to
force the Rule of Nine
on the dependency downstream.
For example, let's say, logging.
You don't have to
require logging
have higher nines
of availability
if you can reconcile, build
a reconcile in your system
that if logging is not
available you still continue
and reconcile later.
So that's some of
the patterns we
have used for non-critical
dependency, where we continue
the operation, continue the
top level API available,
and reconcile later.
RAJESH MISHRA: So that's our
design point number four--
do a fail-open and do
lazy reconciliation.
So in some ways this is like
an eventual reconciliation.
Let's talk a bit about
InstanceTemplate.
Remember, in our
data model, I talked
about InstanceTemplate and
Snapshots are global resources.
So what about them?
Does that pose a problem
for a GCE system?
So I did a deep dive
on InstanceTemplate.
VIKAS YADAV: Yeah,
the reason we want
to talk about
InstanceTemplate is, earlier
we showed you that we have
a separate control stack
for every scope, and there
is a single global scope.
So InstanceTemplate
are global resources
which are sorted out
of a single stack.
So it's important
for us to explain
how we achieve high availability
for InstanceTemplate
and Snapshot.
So Rajesh is going
to talk about that.
RAJESH MISHRA: So
InstanceTemplate
is something that
gets configured.
So this is a typical workflow
of an InstanceTemplate.
You create an InstanceTemplate.
It's a global resource.
And typically a
managed instance group
depends on referencing an
InstanceTemplate, which
is then, in, turn
used by VM creation
within the managed
instance group.
So it's a global resource, and
it creates a global dependency
for something that is a
regional API or a zonal API.
This could be a problem.
So how does autoscaling
or auto healing
within the context of a
managed instance group work?
So by the way, there is
a managed instance group.
Folks are doing a
presentation later today.
They will talk a little
bit in more detail
about regional scaling,
regional autoscaling
and regional managed
instance group.
What's very key for both
autoscaling and auto healing,
you need to be able to create
instances and reference
your template.
So the solution
we've arrived, we
cache InstanceTemplate
in all regions.
We actually do two
levels of caching.
The intuition that
we operated on
is that it was acceptable to
go with eventual consistency
with an AP-based model.
So we just talked about CAP,
and this is the AP model
that we could successfully
apply for InstanceTemplate.
VIKAS YADAV: So the
availability of InstanceTemplate
is high because we cache it.
And what that means is
if a single global scope
or single global stack has a
problem, the InstanceTemplates
which are cached with
the regions and zones,
they are available for
autoscaling and auto healing
to work.
RAJESH MISHRA: And there
are more nuances to this.
And I'm not talking
about all the use cases.
So there are nuances
of, you're trying
to delete an InstanceTemplate,
so what then?
And we can cover that
if there is interest
later in the presentation.
OK.
I built this twice.
My apologies.
So let's spend a
minute on Snapshot.
So Snapshot is another
global resource.
Snapshots are
taken on your disk,
which is a zonal resource.
However, there is something
that we did that we never
exposed to customers.
The underlying
snapshot has always
been a multiregional concept,
except the Snapshot resource
itself, the metadata has
been a global resource.
The GCS buckets where the
physical raw snapshots
are stored, it's a
multiregional concept.
VIKAS YADAV: So
this is important.
If you have a zonal disk,
and you take a snapshot,
you don't have to worry about
that zone not being available
and you not being able
to access your snapshot.
So the metadata for
Snapshot is global,
and it's available via
eventual consistency
in all the other regions.
The GCE bucket where the
snapshot data is stored,
that is multiregional,
and that provides
higher availability for the
actual Snapshot content,
and high availability for
the Snapshot metadata.
So you can imagine a scenario
where your zonal snapshot,
once the zone has trouble,
you can use the snapshot
and utilize that in
some of those zone.
RAJESH MISHRA: So Vikas
already covered this.
There's another thing
that we announced
a GCP Next, which has
been in an alpha mode
for some of our customers.
We're now going to expose
the snapshot locality.
So as I told you, the underlying
multiregional locality
will get exposed.
There was a new parameter
we're exposing called storage
locations.
So you'll be able to learn where
your physical snapshots are
getting stored.
Additionally, we're
going to follow--
we're going to allow you
providing choices for where
your snapshot will get stored.
So this can be done
on your request body
by specifying the specific
multiregional place where
you need to get
your snapshot stored
if you don't want
us to choose, or you
could specify specific regions.
So you could have
your source disk
in the US in any
one of the zonal--
US zones.
And you can pick your regional
destination to be in Europe.
This is what it looks like.
That's a parameter.
So I've given two examples--
storage locations with
just one location, or you
pick a multiregional thing.
So the multiregional
is a GCS construct.
EU simply implies it's
one of the EU regions.
As I explained in
the previous thing,
we will tell you what are the
specific multiregional places
where we place the snapshot on.
So the design point in both
Snapshot and InstanceTemplate
that has worked for us is
eventual consistency and UX.
So let's take a moment
and talk about the UX.
The choice we
could have taken is
we could have converted this
into a regional resource.
We could have deprecated
our existing global resource
and offered regional
equivalents of those.
We felt this was a
good user convenience
to a lot of customers.
Because oftentimes, you
try to create a snapshot
and make them available
in multiple regions,
and you're going to end up
doing the work yourself.
So we're just saving
the burden by taking
on a lot of that complexity
as part of the GCE system.
So the UX was a key point.
So we didn't want
to trade off on some
of the user convenience.
Meanwhile, we could achieve
all the high availability
characteristics by providing
eventual consistency
by caching those resources
in each one of the regions.
So that's our design
point number five.
So this a recap of all the
five design points we covered.
And above all, and
most importantly--
and it's an operational point--
at Google, most services
we carry out something
we call DRT.
DRT is disaster recovery,
and we simulate failures.
We simulate region
unavailability.
We simulate latency.
And we want to make
sure our APIs are well
behaving across all
those failures that
could happen in the real world.
VIKAS YADAV: And
this DRT exercise
is invisible to the customer.
we do it internally.
It's planned, and
we prepare for it.
And we want to see the
system behavior when
disaster recovery is going on.
And this does not impact
any of the external VMs
or external line traffic.
RAJESH MISHRA: So so far,
we've discussed our data model
and the fact that our
resources are either--
are scope resources,
so either they're
zonal, regional, or global.
And you could use control plane
to provision your resources.
And you could do this
on-demand, in real-time
as you're serving traffic,
or you could pre-provision.
So let's apply some lessons.
So there are two
ways to approach
this when it comes to
serving real-time traffic
for critical operations.
So let's imagine you
built this service.
You built a GCE application
that serves 1,000 QPS.
And let's say you did one
of those good best design
practices that we advise on
GCE, and you leverage two zones,
in this case, US East
1A and US East 1B.
In my contrived
example, each VM has
been tested to serve
100 QPS, and they've
been tested for that.
So you have five VMs on the
either side on two zones served
by isolated controlled planes.
And even the VMs are completely
isolated because they are
in two different serving paths.
Imagine you lose
one of the zones.
You're going to double
their traffic on US East 1B.
This may be not desirable,
because you tested your service
for 100 QPS.
So the choices you have--
you would go on-demand
and ask for five more VMs.
There is a possibility
you may not get five VMs,
because we may stock out.
Maybe US West 1A is experiencing
a zone-wide failure,
and every other customer is
trying to do the same thing.
That could be problematic.
So you could pre-provision.
In pre-provisioning, you
will pre-provision five more
instances.
So here you end up
with 10 instances each.
And in reality, the
traffic will look
like this in a steady state.
So you're serving half
what you tested for,
and that may be a
safe place to be.
And in the event
you lose a zone,
you would be safely
able to serve
twice the amount of
traffic, because that's
what you tested for.
So let's recap what we learned.
So if you pre-provision, you're
done with a control plane,
configuring your VMs, the
disks, and all the network
programming that goes with
it, and then, at that point,
your VM is serving live traffic.
And we have published
SLA for that,
and that works out really well.
So the pros are, this
pattern is predictable.
It's simple.
On the downside, it
costs a little bit more,
and in a steady state
or in the average case,
your system's a
little less utilized.
In the on-demand, you
put the control plane
on the critical path.
So here you save on utilization,
and that's an advantage.
That could work out for
some of your use cases.
But this is unpredictable.
If it's Black Friday, you
may not get your instances.
VIKAS YADAV: So
the on-demand model
is where if you run into a
problem in one of your zones,
you try to allocate
in other zones
an equal number of
VMs which you need.
And what Rajesh is pointing
out, it's not a guaranteed
unless they are
reserved or provisioned
that you need x amount of VMs,
you'll get x amount of VMs.
It could be a
stock-out situation,
it could be a
thundering herd problem,
that the zone you want
that's over capacity,
and nobody can get extra VMs.
RAJESH MISHRA: So that
concludes our presentations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]